David were talking today about first
corinthians chapters three and four
where paul is continuing his reflection
on wisdom and where true wisdom resides
but there all sorts of interesting moves
that he makes in here comparing himself
to Apollo's and bringing in a notion of
a day of judgment that's going to be
coming soon what do you make of all that
it's partly what we have been talking
about in our first session which is that
Paul still sees everything he does as
living in the in the promise and threat
I think of Jesus return and what that
will mean in terms of judgment and in
this case he's not talking so much about
individual judgment what happens to the
individual Christian he's talking about
how the work that he's done as an
apostle and the work that Apollo's has
done as a missionary will be judged at
the last day and clearly the strong
sense is that everything they do stands
under both the promise and the threat of
God in Jesus Christ and therefore they
are eternally responsible for the way
they do their pastoral work and they
will be called to account for it kind of
a heavy response it's a hugely heavy
responsibility mm-hmm at the same time
he's said relating to his community here
in some interesting ways isn't they well
the interesting thing for me is there
are a couple places at the beginning
where he talks about what he's feeding
them and then the later when he talks
about himself as being their father that
he that he takes on a very familial
paternal role with these congregations
and I think that means partly that like
a good father he nurtures them but
partly like a good father he disciplines
them and I've been puzzled about the the
passage in here about being imitators of
him and so often that goes back to what
we talked about in our last conversation
which is the danger of Paul's boasting
that he wants to be deeply humble but
has a hard time doing that and normally
if a pastor stands up and says to his
congregation I've got really good advice
for you which is be imitators of me we
get extremely nervous about how much
hubris is involved in that and what
we'll find out about him or her in the
next two days it's always it's not
necessarily good news but here I think
if you see it in the familial image that
that one of the things I think we pray
for when we are parents is that we will
be the kind of human being that we want
our children to imitate it isn't perfect
it isn't always exemplary but the way we
live our lives I think we do live with
them in mind saying what kind of adults
are they going to be if they follow the
kind of adulthood they see in us and I
think in that sense it's pastoral and
even loving to say imitate me because
like a father I'm trying to nurture you
and to chide you but only to charge you
that you can grow up in Christ this is
one of those points to I think where
Paul's background in greco-roman
philosophy might be coming to the fore
because most philosophers had came to
Ithaca questions with the notion of
virtue as yeah I'm very much so and the
way you learn virtue was by observing so
Paul might be a little bit because of an
exemplar like some like the good
philosophical leader that he is in some
ways I'm conceptually right yeah there
are at least two or three other places
in the text we he'll put himself forward
as a major example of they the virtue
that he wants to inculcate exactly
exactly I'll be seeing that later
there's another theme that pops up here
that's going to be interesting as it
develops in first Corinthians this is in
chapter 3 verse 16 do you not know that
you are the God's Temple yeah and that
God's Spirit dwells in you
where was this coming from and where is
it going well it's coming I think from
his strong sense that that that the
promise that that Judaism had that the
Temple in Jerusalem was the place where
God dwelled has now been transcended not
necessarily destroyed but transcended by
a sense that temple language is now
language for the God who has broken
loose from relationship to any
particular place or any particular
ethnic community and that he wants to
say that that now the temple is God's
dwelling in us and that very much
qualifies the way in which we're
supposed to live Christian people are
supposed to live because we we live not
only for ourselves and our bodies are
not only our own property but they are
the place where God dwells it also picks
up on the language he starts here about
being a master builder and a planter
he's talking about the way in which
they're up to what what he and Apollo's
had been up to is his friendly
competitor is not for their own sake but
for the sake of building up a church and
building up a community and now building
up individual Corinthians who represent
that temple in wood
spirits dwells mm-hmm yeah I think
there's an interesting exchange between
the temple as a symbol of the community
and that's something that he definitely
gets out of his Jewish heritage the
sectarian Qumran for instance thought of
their little community as the new
general and then he'll also when he
starts talking about sexual morality in
the next couple of chapters talk about
the individual body as the temple spirit
yeah and there's some sort of important
correlation between the community burger
is temporary body and the individual
body both as low sigh of true
spirituality yeah absolutely
and here he may be resisting that
concern with the spiritual that he
alluded to very nice yeah that divorces
it from from the actual embodiment and
then when you get to what a church is it
is embodiment even more as well and one
of the things we've worried about in 1st
Corinthians one of the things he worries
about I think is the whole range of ways
in which the Corinthian people seem to
believe that their faith their
spirituality their religious experience
we move them from the kind of ethical
constraints of how you eat how you
relate to other people sexually how you
relate to other people as a body and he
always wants to say still a body still
human still materials still and fleshed
think about what faith means to
inflation people not to some how people
liberated from the spiritual from the
physical life right if there's one thing
that I admire by about Paulus's realism
hugely hugely realistic usually
concerned with how people actually
relate to one another end and he he
testifies to what we all know from our
own experience which is that to move
into a community of faith is not to move
out of issues like what should eat and
who you sleep with and the church budget
those things are all still with us year
after year after year
anything more to be said about Apollo's
and Paul as apostles well the Apostle
language is very interesting because it
comes come from the Greek word I send so
these are people who are sent there's I
have a little suspicion with Paul here
and some of the other letters too that
he's defensive of the fact that he
really is an apostle
it's it's clear to everybody in the
first communities of the church that
Peters an apostle and James is an
apostle and the sons of Zebedee are
apostles is Paul really an apostle and
at some versions of the Apostolic story
say apostles are only those who
accompany Jesus in his Galilean ministry
that's kind of what Luke wants to say
about it Paul wants to redefine
Apostleship I think in at least two ways
or at least further defined it way one
is you're sent you are one sent by God
and in that sense he's absolutely clear
that's who he is
very much as the prophets were said I
think sometimes being apostle is like
being in a prophet being a prophet for
him I am sent I am sent with a message
and he the part 2 is you have to see the
risen Lord and everybody is clear that
in the early church tradition Peter sees
the risen Lord and bunches of other
people see there was ignored now Paul
comes along sometime later not in
Galilee or Jerusalem but on the road to
Damascus slam some kind of enormous
light experience we don't know the
details and now he says hello me too
I've seen the risen Lord so I've got the
two things you need I'm sent and I've
seen the risen Lord and therefore I'm
apostle too and carry with that all the
authority an apostle oughta have mm-hmm
and there were some people who dispute
that and there are thirty people to
dispute that and even more in second
Corinthians and it's partly because he
doesn't seem to be part of the original
twelve and it's partly because he's not
as impressive as some of the other
apostles in terms of the kinds of signs
he does and miracles he does and maybe
he's not as impressive as an eloquent
speaker as a publicist
but my teacher nils Dahl I meant to talk
about this you know in one of our
earlier sessions you probably have read
this but he thought that maybe one of
the reasons for the issue about disputes
is should we be setting this letter to
Paul at all that is some people are
saying I belong to Paul some people are
saying I belong to Apollo's the I belong
to Paul people are saying all right
we've got all these troubles in church
let's ask Paul the I belong to Apollo's
people say well why don't we just ask a
palace and the I belong to Christ people
are saying let's pray about it I suppose
something like that but but the dahle
issue is very nice as the occasion of
the dispute is this very letter and that
what a part of what Paul has to argue is
that he's a very good person to check in
with on these things because he really
is an apostle and even though he's not
there
authority should count and you do see
him trying with all humility and
inordinate pride to keep insisting that
his opinion counts mm-hmm he's not only
an apostle but also a father yep and as
father he brings the the weight of male
Authority it does bring the way to male
authority that's an issue of the bleb to
be said we're gonna have to look at that
a lot and unlike a palace he's the one
he's the true father he's really he's
sweet - Apollo's nopales as is an
extraordinarily good second order leader
among you you have many teachers in
Christ you have one father oh my god
it's me and I think that there are ways
in which he's not willing to let that go
but we'll see all through this and all
through his letters that the tricky
business of how one can be both
authoritative and loving simultaneously
which is a good question for Father's
Day and is this a common concern of
pastors generally to this day fathers or
mothers how do you how do you how do you
mix the nurturing role and the
authoritative role and I think he tried
to do that powerfully and sometimes not
very effectively like all of us ever
since
well it'll be interesting to watch him
do it there will chapters to go we look
forward to it